thanks for coming to the 2015 ethics
politics and economics meet the author
talk great turnout this year we really
appreciate you guys showing up um so
this is going to be an economics lecture
and I guess it makes sense to start by
talking about trade-offs specifically
the trade-off you've all made in being
here right now instead of outside where
it's 75 degrees and sunny professor
easily has the misfortune to have shown
up on the nicest day of the year to give
a lecture in a basement so I think it's
an interesting decision that you've all
decided made the trade off to be here
right now instead of outside because I'm
sure that a nonzero percentage of people
the people in this room have also made
the decision to hit the snooze button
instead of going to micro in the morning
so if we put on your our economist caps
we can ask ourselves why is that why
have some people in this room chosen to
come to this economics lecture on this
beautiful day despite having doze
through economics lectures in the past
and I think the answer is Bill easterly
and it's my pleasure to welcome him to
yell this afternoon a researcher at the
World Bank from nineteen eighty five to
two thousand one professor easterly has
since taken up residence at NYU where he
teaches economics and is the head of
nyu's award-winning Development Research
Institute the author of three books a
non-resident senior fellow at the
brother at the Brookings Institute and
according to his website the 11th most
famous native of Bowling Green Ohio
professor easterly is a prominent critic
of the standard approach to foreign aid
and in his work at NYU he was taken he
has taken the lead in developing an
alternative paradigm for international
development he's been featured on CNN
and the BBC and in the New York Times
and The Wall Street Journal just to name
a few professor used to lose talk today
shares part of its title with his most
recent work 2013's the tyranny of
experts economist dictators and the
Forgotten right to the porn and it was
after reading that book that we decided
to ask professor Eastley to come and
give a lecture we being the EPA
departments meet the author committee
made up of myself and for other students
who are here today who were tasked with
reading a series of books over the
summer and then choosing one of the
authors to invite to come and give a
talk at Yale so we reconvened in the
fall having read the books and I
actually have to say it was a very easy
choice the tyranny of experts combined
historical and contemporary evidence
with economic analysis to suggest that a
top-down approach to
in the developing world might in fact be
strengthening authoritarian rulers at
the expense of those that the
international community is trying to
help I won't say much more about it I'll
leave that to the author but I do want
to talk about what made the book really
stand out to wast on committee so EPA
the name of the department hosting the
stock stands for ethics politics and
economics three things that academia
generally keeps in separate compartments
but Professor easterlies book combines
them all which made it a natural choice
for us of course there's plenty of
economics it's a book about
international development and professor
easterly offers compelling arguments
about why some nations haven't developed
economically and what can be done to
change that but part of that economic
argument is about politics professor
easterly writes that well intentioned
foreign aid becomes counterproductive
when it strengthens dictators and
autocrats who in turn undermine not just
economic but the political rights of the
world's poor and finally at the heart of
the book is a moral claim that those in
the economic development community need
to change their ways if they don't want
to be complicit and oppression professor
easily blends these three ostensibly
separate disciplines with ease for one
simple reason his book is about the real
world where ethics politics and
economics are inextricably intertwined
which brings us back to the question I
posed earlier why have some people in
this room chosen to come to this
economics lecture despite having skipped
other economics lectures in the past
undergraduates in their first econ class
often end up wondering what all the talk
about utility curves and two-person
exchange economies has to do with real
world and when those questions go and
answered that this new that the snooze
button starts looking like a utility
maximizing option but you don't have to
wonder about the real world relevance of
Professor easterlies work and I think
that's why we're all so excited here and
speak so without further ado Billy
thank you David for that very warm
introduction really appreciate it it's
really a pleasure to be here let me do a
sound check first of all some of you
might be surprised that I'm a lot more
mild mannered in person than I seem to
be in the writings so my voice doesn't
carry that well can you hear me in the
back raise your hand if you cannot hear
me this is the real way you test
hypotheses and economics it only if you
cannot hear me raise your hand okay I
still don't believe you because does
this thing help is this actually
amplifying anything no okay this is not
amplifying anything right okay are you
guys good try again anyone who cannot
hear me talking right now asking this
question actually that's kind of a
metaphysical thing if you couldn't hear
me then you wouldn't be able to answer
well nevermind so let me jump right in
the claim in this book and in this talk
is going to be that the mainstream
approach to development can often lead
to an unintentional tyranny of experts
that neglects the rights of poor people
how exactly could that happen so let me
just start out straight away with what
we think of very often when we think
about doing development we think of a
series of technical problems that caused
the poor to be poor that caused the poor
to suffer ill health poor education low
income and we think of technical
solutions that would really alleviate a
lot of those problems directly so for
example we might think of thing and
what's nice about these technical
solutions and the why the reason they're
so popular in development debates is
because they're so tangible and so clear
how they lead to a solution so you might
think of say malnutrition part of
malnutrition is vitamin deficiency
there's some very
simple inexpensive remedies like vitamin
A capsules the remedy vitamin A
deficiency that improve the problem of
Mike of malnutrition it's extremely
straightforward and appealing that you
could just solve that dimension with
something so simple and direct and
inexpensive malaria malaria is carried
by mosquitoes as I hope all of you know
and you want to kill the mosquitoes one
of the best ways to do that people have
found is you spray the walls of people's
indoor walls at people's houses where
they're going to be sleeping when
they're most at risk from being bitten
by mosquitoes with a chemical called
pyrethrum that kit when the mosquitoes
land on the wall that kills them then
they can't transmit malaria it's you
know you assemble enough technical
solutions like this and it sounds like
you're starting to have some very
convincing answers for the problems of
poverty or did it take another example
maybe some piece of land is not very
fertile for growing food crops it'd be a
lot more fertile for growing a forest
that you could sell forest products then
you just need technical forestry advice
this last example is actually relevant
because now I'm going to give you a
example that shows some of the
shortcomings of this purely technical
approach to development which often
claims to be a political it claims to be
ethically neutral speaking of ethics
morally neutral so let's let's take an
example about what some of the
limitations of that approach might be so
I'm going to tell you a story that
begins on the morning of februari 28
2010 a little over more than five years
ago some villagers in mubende a district
uganda woke up to the sound of gunfire
some of them woke up some of them were
in church when they heard the sound of
gunfire they came running out of their
homes and out of the church and soldiers
with guns or please make yourself
comfortable
you're very welcome I don't take it
personally that you're late sorry so
back to the story so sorry I'm just
using you your figure fine the villagers
are mubende a district why were they why
were there men with guns in move and a
district uganda men we're shooting their
cattle they were driving people at at
gunpoint from their homes and then they
started to burn down the homes and they
torched the crops and kept people at
gunpoint away from rescuing their homes
and crops and why were they doing this
that this was a World Bank forestry
project that the World Bank had financed
a private company that together decided
they needed the land for a forestry
project and the way they implemented
this project was to march families who
had been on this land for generations
off their land at gunpoint and start the
forestry project as one thing that's
unusual about the story and unlike many
other similar rights violations that
happen and so it's fairly obvious right
away what the problem is here right that
you hit you thought you had an
apolitical ethically neutral time to go
solution but you actually grossly
violated the rights the basic human
rights and land rights of poor people
and to show you give you an indication
of how that the development community as
a whole the whole business of doing
development is not really that sensitive
to these issues let me tell you about
what happened next so there's one really
unusual thing that happened next is that
Oxfam heard about this and they
publicized it in a report which in turn
got the attention of the New York Times
and this whole story actually appeared
on the front page of the New York Times
and actually on September in September
of 2011 but then app so you would have
thought if anyone was ever going to be
held accountable for a rights violation
and development this would be the time
you're on the front page of New York
Times World Bank is directly accused by
the New York Times of financing rights
relations and I was writing a blog
called aid watch while this was going on
and really monitoring this in in real
time and what I noticed next were were
two non-events the World Bank actually
the day the story came out they said oh
we will investigate but then someone's
calling me it might be the World Bank no
yeah they're investigating the World
Bank promised that day on Twitter that
they were doing an investigation that
investigation has never happened they
never did an investigation they never
considered in what way they were might
have been responsible for this tragic
event that happened the second non-event
was that nobody in development really
protested this is really the World Bank
really did get away with this because
the World Bank never did an
investigation into their own actions it
would have identified what they did
wrong to make this tragic event happen
and then nobody really protested in
development so they've never really had
to face the consequences of what
happened on sep tember on originally
happened on februari 28 2010 now more
than five years ago so why is that it's
because every there is so many people in
development that are focused on these
technik technocratic what we call
technocratic approach to development
technocrat is a combination of technical
and autocrat that you think you have a
technical solution but that the people
who are actually implementing the
technical solutions are authoritarian
actors they're actors that don't face
any democratic accountability to the
people that they are that they are
affecting that they're whose rights they
are violating so the people involved in
the story oh the autocratic government
of Uganda and the autocratic actor of
the world bank that has no mechanism for
democratic accountability to the people
whose projects the people that it the
World Bank is directly affecting with
its own projects so that's the problem
in this whole story is that there is no
accountability now
let's start talking about rights first
of all and this has been the point so
far is that rights are obviously a moral
and in and of themselves the poor people
have rights to their own land that they
should not be coerced at gunpoint to
give up their own lands and be forced to
move somewhere else they don't want to
go that's a moral violation in and of
itself and we should care about that and
that really is by itself enough of a
reason to talk a lot about human rights
political rights economic rights in
development and and actually I I wish
all of us would be satisfied with that
that we wouldn't ask anything else that
rights do and that we would still want
rights just in and of themselves because
they're we want our rights respected we
think everyone else's route should be
respected also that's a moral cause now
I do have to say as an economist we're
not usually talking in this way that I'm
talking right now we're not usually
talking about about moral issues like
violating for people's rights and so I I
one instinct is a little bit of an
advantage that you guys are from a
program that has the word ethics and at
that [ __ ] better than my usual audience
of a economic student so I usually feel
like I'm to apologize as an economist
for talking about these seemingly
sentimental moral emotional issues like
rights it's like I'm confessing I cry at
the end of Hollywood romantic comedies
or something it's you know it's a really
embarrassing kind of position for an
economist to be in I want to argue that
it's actually quite natural position for
an economist of you for a couple of
reasons first of all all these boring
classes that David does not want to go
to that he wants to sleep through what
what kind what are the models actually
based on their based on individuals
making their own choices acting in their
own interests making their own choices
acting their own interests individuals
who are free to choose who are not
coerced to do something they don't want
to do so all of our basic models and
economics are presuming a basic rights
infrastructure that people's rights are
respected and so if an economist is
suddenly transported to some place where
that is not true then it's it's
incumbent
The Economist to point it out that hey
our usual assumptions don't apply here
because these you're dealing with
someone violating someone else's rights
not letting them be free to choose
coercing them there's a more wonky way
to put this which is economists have
this principle called revealed
preference which as usual and economics
is a really boring confusing terminology
for a really simple concept it's simply
that people reveal by what they buy
their choices what they want this felt
that's hosted it means it's called
revealed preference so we need that
principle to be sure that we're actually
making people better off that people are
free to choose we need that to be in
place to be sure that we're actually
making people better off so in this
example if if we had been sure that the
mubende a farmers had been free to
choose and had voluntarily consented to
selling their land to a forestry company
or to the World Bank that would have
been fine then we could infer that they
had they were better off because they
had voluntarily decided to sell their
land to give up their land for a price
to the forestry company on the World
Bank as we call revealed preference we
need that to be sure they're better off
if people are coerced to do something
and actually we're pretty sure they're
probably worse off because coercion
would not be necessary unless it was
something they that they felt would make
them worse off that's when coercion is
necessary so it is economists do have a
language and do have at the center of
our models these concerns with rights
and then finally and not most
importantly but is it but it is
important we do of course also want to
know whether rights are actually good
for producing the other thing we care
about which is material development
which is relief from material poverty
and here I don't have time to kind of
sketch out any kind of elaborate body of
theory and evidence but I'll just sort
of take it as fairly obvious and those
of you have technique noms classes will
know that this is pretty much the
consensus and economics that yes a
society in which people are free to make
their own economic choices and political
choices
is one that is likely to solve the
problem better than a society that is
coercing people against their will why
is that well in the market we know how
easily that works if people are free to
to buy whatever they want from whomever
they want and and the suppliers are free
to compete and enter and compete with
each other to meet the needs of
consumers we're pretty sure that's a
system that's going to result in making
people's needs get met so that's kind of
our first basic layer of econ 101 that
we think this system of rights that
people are free to choose actually
results in successful problem solving a
very successful problem solving system
and the same sort of principles sort of
hold in politics not quite as clearly
and we don't model them quite quite as
simply as we do in the markets but the
same principles Holden in politics if
people are free to choose their
governments and free to choose between
different political parties and actors
that are competing to be in the
government and people have their own
their own rights protected against the
government doing harm to them and can
protest vociferously if the government
does do any harm to them well then
that's a situation where the government
is not likely to to do as much harm to
them when the people are free to protest
and free to vote that abusive government
out of power that's a situation where
people are more likely to not have their
rights violated to not have their
problems trampled upon and more
positively when they're they're choosing
between political entrepreneurs who are
competing to solve their their public
goods needs supplying higher quality
health services and education services
and and roads this doesn't work
perfectly but it it does work that when
there's competition to supply these
public needs that the voters and the
political protesters will reward the
politicians that supply the public goods
and they will penalize the politicians
that don't supply the public goods I'm a
few states over here we have a new
jersey governor we just caused one
little traffic jam on a bridge and a
destroyed this whole presidential
campaign thank God sorry the last part
is off the record you know it's to even
put this in in
more explicit terms think of take the MU
bend a story and suppose you had
transposed that too I think of it
transposing it to my home state or hum
stick home part of a state Northwest
Ohio which is farm country do you think
if you know the the World Bank and an
autocratic Ohio government had gone with
guns blazing and driven farmers off
their off their land in Ohio that they
would have gotten away with no
investigation with no consequences that
nobody would have protested do you
really think that that would have
happened now is this is the sort of we
forget about the biggest virtue of
democracy is often what does not happen
in democracy there's lots and lots of
bad things that doesn't that do not
happen in democracy because we have the
right to protest and the right to vote
abusive and bad rulers out of power now
I'm very far from arguing that it's a
perfect utopia and wonderful solution
all problems are instantly solved of
course not and we have a Congress whose
approval rating is no longer detectable
by modern methods we have a
terrible-looking presidential campaign
there's lots of bad stuff that happens
in democracy there's this basic currency
of protest and mobilization and voting
that you can be sure that any politician
who does is going to do horrible things
to the voters or totally failed to
deliver the most basic public services
is going to pay a political price that
is the basic 101 of democracy that is
like the market 101 of private suppliers
meeting needs so that's the kind of kind
of basic approach to development that
surprisingly is it's neglected in this
whole technical approach to development
we neglect the whole atmosphere of
Rights that is necessary to make
problems get solved both public problems
and private problems so let me give you
some more examples of how popular this
technocratic approaches Bill Gates is is
a good example of someone who seems very
much in love with the technocratic
approach let me take you to another
country where Bill Gates is operating a
lot Ethiopia Bill Gates wrote an article
in which he praised the Ethiopian
government for setting clear goals
choosing an approach measuring result
and then using these measurements to
continually refine our approach our I
guess met him and the European
government working together the
Ethiopian government at that time was
actually a not very lovely autocrat
named Melissa now II who himself had a
long string of human rights violations
and volunteer another involuntary
resettlement story that I'm going to
tell you in a moment so this is the
essence of the technocratic solution the
technical experts work with the autocrat
to implement the technical solutions not
realizing that the neglecting the
atmosphere of Rights that needs to exist
for these problems really to be
lastingly solved gates doesn't quite get
this he's this sentence that I just
quoted you clear goals measuring results
using measurements to continually refine
our approach experts and autocrats
Alliance approach this helps us deliver
this is another quote from gates this
helps us deliver tools and services to
everybody who will benefit us again who
does he mean by us the Gates Foundation
and utopian autocrat working together do
everybody who will benefit it's a very
strong claim for a list of technical
solutions that's operating in a right
where the actually the Ethiopian
government is also pursuing involuntary
resettlement schemes as an exact
parallel to the Uganda story that I
could tell you what the gambella region
of Ethiopia where a projects financed by
the British aid agency and the World
Bank and USAID are resettling also
resettling farmers at gunpoint and
moving them to Ethiopian government
sponsored so-called model villages that
are anything but model villages so all
of these abuses are also going on this
and this second wave of examples and yet
Bill Gates is under the illusion that
this technocratic approach measuring
results clear goals we deliver tools and
services to everybody who will benefit
so it's I have to confess Bill Gates
sort of became the perfect technocrat
example for me to use as kind of a
someone punching bag sorry sort of like
he's my new kind of Jeff Sachs his
he's so technocratic he might embarrass
other technocrats but and then
unfortunately melis who is one of my
favorite examples died a natural causes
in late 2012 but then gates praised his
equally autocratic successor Haile
Mariam for his thoughtfulness and
knowledge as well as his commitment to
continuing the policies of Prime
Minister's own are we now let me at this
point try to be as to bend backwards as
far as possible to be fair to the other
side maybe Gates is really only thinking
about a maybe he really is only thinking
about what we could call aid instead of
gel that there are a few technical
problems that Gates could actually make
better with his foundation with some
technical solutions and that's okay
there's nothing wrong with that if he's
making poor people's lives better
directly with his foundation with these
technical solutions that's okay but it's
not development it's maybe you know
humanitarian aid its alleviation of
short-term alleviation of suffering
short term alleviation of suffering is
grapes because I'm all for that but it's
not development and we're so what
creates the unintentional tyranny of
experts is that first of all gates does
not realize the difference between aid
and development that aid is like this
tiny little mouse and development is its
huge elephant which is mainly homegrown
efforts of people around the world for
their own development and he's confusing
the two and second of all Gates himself
becomes then a major player in the
debates on rights and development
democracy and development dictatorship
and development because Gates is a very
important player in 8 he becomes a very
important participant in in in
development debates so let's be as kind
as possible the gates maybe he thinks he
has to say nice things about the
Ethiopian government to do his his
technical solutions in Ethiopia maybe he
has to play nice with the government and
there was that dilemma and so he
basically has to censor himself to be
able to operate in Ethiopia which and
that might be okay except
for the fact that he's also this big
player in the big debate on to democracy
autocracy and and poor people's rights
oops i just did something relate that
could be really disastrous for your
computer sorry i just spilled water on
your computer no you have a dear do you
have a paper towel I do this every talk
it's great for kind of breaking up the
monotony I was really getting bored of
not having my computer thank you that's
great thank you I got so excited about
gates sorry sorry about that David send
me the bill actually ascended the gates
he's he can afford it wow I'm really
sorry it I think it really will dry out
why don't you unplug it so you don't
electrocute yourself
turn it off and put upside down okay
yeah we're not going we're not going to
use we're going to be without slides
yeah yeah just put it upside down and
let it dry out we'll negotiate us a
technical solution to this later okay
okay well that was a little bit of a
buzzkill but let's let's try to get back
on track here oh yeah yeah awesome oh
yeah well working it later I've heard
that water is actually not as disastrous
everything for a season just try it will
have to dry out okay so let me try to
bring your attention back to the big
point which is gates is self-censoring
himself to participate in in an aid
program in ethiopia that would be okay
but then he's also got this article on
the front page of The Wall Street
Journal weekend section and we're
presenting his whole approach to
development and it's about enabling
justifying an autocratic regime that is
violating the rights of Ethiopians
resettling them at gunpoint from their
own lands and moving them to the
government villages that have notes of
basic services so the problem here is
it's really to be fair to all the aid
people all the eight experts who did not
intend to be tyrannical who did not
intend to neglect rights on their own
they may privately Express and Gates
himself my privately expresses his
desire that that rights are a good thing
that democracy is a good cause the
problem is simply that the technical
eight actors have to censor themselves
and then they in turn are the main
participants and development debate so
we have a self-centered we have a sensor
development debate that's the
unintentional tyranny of experts of
everyone in development are
all the main actors and development are
trying to provide aid through autocratic
regimes censoring themselves not they're
not allowing themselves criticize
autocrats to criticize rights violations
so we have a highly censored debate that
never considers how autocrats maybe both
morally and pragmatically wrong for poor
people that's the unintentional tyranny
of experts that we wind up with after
the technocratic approach lives itself
out so the big the big question is
really even stronger than that it's it's
that the aid regime and the regime that
that favors the technocratic approach is
is itself politically convenient in
another way and that is that the one
thing going on here it's not only that
aid is going to ethiopian Uganda because
technical actors are trying to do
technical solutions there's another
thing going on here the politics of aid
is that Ethiopian Uganda are both major
allies of the US and the war on terror
and so I think you're familiar with
history of aid to know that aid was used
a lot during the Cold War to go to us
allies against the Soviets if this is
happening again i'm not i'm sure this
won't surprise you in the war on terror
that aid development aid is going to
allies of the US and the war on terror
and so this idea of so technocratic
political neutrality is awfully welcome
to us political actors who don't want to
talk about rights violations of
governments that they need on their side
for the war on terror and so basically
it's this self-censor debate is self
centered in another way that the
development actors realize they can form
kind of an alliance with the national
security interest you just want to you
know they and the national security
interest is a legitimate interest I'm
not I'm not questioning the legitimacy
of the US need to defend itself against
terrorists but what's happening in this
case is the there are a lot of rights
violations that are indirectly happening
because of the US war on terror
autocratic allies and with the way that
the technocratic approach to development
is awfully convenient for these guys is
that it enables them to get a whole
nother body of political support for
supporting autocratic regimes which is
the humanitarian aid community that is
convinced that they can work with the
autocrats delivers the relief to poor
people in these countries and so we have
a kind of Alliance of humanitarians and
national security interests politicians
it's another prediction of political
economy is that politicians always want
to maximize the share of the votes they
get that's very obvious prediction and
political economy so if you have to
separate lobbies that you can gain with
one set of ideas that you want autocrats
for the war on terror and you have some
idea of kind of benevolent developmental
autocrats who are allegedly developing
their own countries with the help of US
aid and World Bank aid those that set of
ideas is very convenient for getting
this nice alliance of a sort of the
national security interests you want the
autocrats for the war on terror and the
humanitarian interests who will overlook
the autocratic regimes because they're
under the illusion that there can be a
technocratic solution to development
that you can just deliver the technical
solutions without ever having to
question the human rights violations of
the autocrats that you're working with
so one way to to put this and and so of
course the what is not possible onto
that set of ideas is to challenge the
status quo but this status quo is
actually leading to a lot of rights
violations of poor people that is
actually bad for them in itself and bad
for development so another way to help
illustrate the way that his technocratic
ideas are politically useful are to sort
of go back to their historical origins
this is something that I actually had a
lot of a lot of fun researching and
reading about in the research for this
book is to go back and to trace the
historical origins of the idea of
technocratic development the development
was just a long list of technical
solutions that you could ignore the
political regime under which those
technical solutions are happening so
there were the first time in history
that that's
pepin was actually under colonial rule
so colonial rule is another set of
autocrats except in this case the
autocrat is say for the British Empire
of the British colonial office secretary
of state for the colonies and they are
the ones who really in the 1930s and 40s
and in Africa and earlier in China in
the 1920s and 1930s and around the same
time in Latin America working with some
unlovely Latin American autocrats so to
pioneer this technocratic approach the
development look the British colonial
authorities were very happy about these
technocratic ideas because they allowed
them to sidestep the whole issue of
ending colonial rule of granting
independence to the colonies which is
starting to become an issue in the 20th
century of course although at that time
in the 30s and 40s the world the British
expected the colonial empire took to
continue indefinitely so there's lots of
examples of very similar technocratic
approaches that during the colonial
period in in the 1930s one slide that I
lost by by pouring water over David's
computer is a comparison of technocratic
solutions in 1938 and today so I've
already played a little trick on you
that I apologize for you didn't realize
remember when I said one technical
solution was vitamin A capsules to
malnutrition that was mentioned in a
1938 colonial report called a massive
thousand-page colonial report which if
you if you don't behave properly during
this lecture I'm going to force you to
read a thousand-page colonial report
called an African survey led by a
British colonial official name Lord
Haley the 1938 he had already proposed
vitamin A capsules for malnutrition I
also set you up to consider pyrethrum
spraying on the walls of houses that was
also already in the nineteen
thirty-eight survey colonial survey
written in 1938 which is when during a
period when colonial rule is expected to
continue forever and ever at least the
Lord Haley wanted it
continue forever and ever he made
statements like political liberties are
meaningless unless they can be built on
a better foundation of social and
economic progress social economic
progress meaning the technical solutions
that the colonial authorities are
offering her and another British
official said in 1943 we should not
concentrate on the pursuit of political
ideals very similar statements are made
today why are you talking about
political ideals when we have all these
nice surgical solutions to poor people's
problems the colonial authority said
don't talk about political ideals that
would be to the detriment of the
preeminent need for improving the
physical and social conditions that's an
exact quote from the British colonial
report in 1943 so the idea even already
back then was that we can we can justify
colonial rule as the benevolent autocrat
that is delivering material development
and you know take it's just one way to
think about the technocratic idea is
it's like a massive sort of distraction
principle it's like don't look at the
rights violations over here that we're
imposing foreign colonial rule on
hundreds of millions of people against
their will look at the technical
solutions over here that the colonial
authorities are supplying to meet the
needs of poor colonial subjects that's
the same distraction principle that is
going on today Gates is saying don't
look at the human rights violations
being directly financed by by the way
the the Ethiopian resettlement project
is also directly being financed by the
World Bank USAID and the British aid
diffent so it's the aid agencies and the
US foreign policy makers today are
saying don't look at these rights
violations over here look at the
technical solutions over here and that
is the railing and sidetracking any
debate that would that would question
the status quo that would question the
status quo of both either in colonial
times or in Cold War times or war on
terror times in which there's an
alliance of Western interests with
humanitarian interests that both are all
working together for something that
sounds very good technical solutions to
poor people but why
upside tracking d railing and silencing
the debate on rights for poor people
that we should be having that we should
have been having back then in colonial
times that we should be having now of
course back then in colonial times we
did eventually have have that debate but
unfortunately what happened after that
was the Cold War so that the the new
rulers of the independent states after
the end of colonialism were often
autocrats that were still supported by
US foreign policy in US aid with the
same kind of alliance of humanitarian a
national security interest or in the
Cold War and then that leads up to what
I already told you to about today's
status quo of the war on terror so
that's the sense in which the
technocratic approach it sounds good as
a set of technical solutions to poor
people's problems but it profoundly does
a big disservice to the cause of human
rights political rights of political and
economic freedom for poor people it
silences and sidetrack set debate that
we should be having and so that debate
has never really happened so let me give
you one final sort of political example
that again gives you a sense of why
technocratic ideas are not quite the
right solution for poor people and this
one I can put in the context of US
history a group that it was afflicted
with a lot of rights violations in
poverty in US history and that is the
case of American blacks and the
discrimination and rights violations and
poverty that they suffered what's
interesting is that around the same time
that Lord Haley and British colonial
officials were writing about the
technocratic justification for colonial
rule FDR during the New Deal and during
World War two but it was trying to
convince blacks that the solution to
their needs were also technical
solutions that the US government was
offering technical material relief to
poor black southerners in the south and
was that enough to actually make change
no something else happened to make
change it was the civil rights movement
so this was sort of started when to give
you an example in 1940 Eleanor Roosevelt
had lunch with the black leader Ralph
Bunche who was fighting for the end of
segregation and her rights for black
Americans and suggested to him that
racism racism was quote most effectively
attacked on the economic front so that's
you know right away again the technical
material solutions white new dealers
tried to convince blacks that they
should quote concentrate on the
attainable goal of economic progress and
to postpone the challenge to segregation
to postpone the challenge to their
violation of their rights that's the
same sort of request as being made to us
today about rights violations we keep
indefinitely forever and ever postponing
the discussion of rights violations to
some future happy day after all the
technical solutions of poverty have been
have been solved and that technocratic
dream is an illusion of course what
happened with American blacks is
something very different happened a set
of black leaders came along that were
not content with technocratic solutions
it did demand their rights so Martin
Luther King came along and he he did not
come up with a set of what what usually
happens with technocratic solutions is
we have you know at the end of a
discussion in which of solving material
property we have a long list of
technical remedies it's sort of like the
the plan mentality to action plan
mentality you know what should we do to
end poverty we should give vitamin A
capsules we should do forestry projects
you know we should provide textbooks for
education we have a long list of
technical solutions we should spray
pyrethrum on the walls of malaria houses
and this gives the illusion of
tangibility to the technocratic approach
to the sons seems to sound so appealing
that we have an action plan to solve
technical poverty in a technical way but
of course the problem with action plans
is they don't they don't necessarily
lead to action the World Bank it calls
itself the knowledge bank and it is full
of action plan
it's overflowing with action plans but
there's one set of World Bank economists
that did a study recently on on how much
the world bank's own knowledge reports
on revealing its action plans for the
technocratic solutions to poverty how
much they they're actually read or cited
they found that one-third of all World
Bank reports have never been downloaded
they're available online there they took
hundreds of man-hours and you know
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
produce available online but no one has
ever downloaded them that's presuming
that the download will actually lead to
reading but it's not even downloaded in
87 reports eighty-seven percent of World
Bank reports have never been cited you
know to have influenced you need to have
someone else say oh the world bank
report said this and that was the answer
and we're going to do action based on
this world bank recommend it's never
been cited so nobody's noticed it even
if it was downloaded so let's contrast
that with Martin Luther King he did not
get on the steps the washington memorial
and say I have a plan he said I have a
dream so you know people are very
dismissive of this kind of sentimental
emotional appeal to the value of human
rights the moral value of human rights
for poor people the moral value of
political and economic rights for poor
people and yet what is what is it that
people actually remember they don't
remember the World Bank reports that all
the thousands of action plans from think
tanks and aid agencies they remember
Martin Luther King I have a dream
arguing not for material solutions but
arguing that black people would be free
at last free at last free at last that's
what that's what sticks that's what is
itself a powerful force for for change
so another slide that that I lost from
the computer is actually very well
represented by this slide I was going to
click and show you my action plan which
is this
this really is my action plan my answer
to the excess abundance of action plans
is not to give you another action plan
that's I have no action plan I have a
blank slide the problem of poverty is
not a shortage of action plan it's not a
shortage of technical solutions the
shortage of Rights and so the
intellectual and moral case advocating
for rights for poor people that has far
more power to end poverty than a set of
action plans you find whatever I wrote
on my last page here now of course a
campaign for rights is itself not not
easy there can be a lot of setbacks it's
going to be slow slower than you would
like advocacy itself often fails you
have to be very patient for that the
people who are most patient are those
whose rights themselves are being
violated so the main agents of change
are the people who poor people
themselves whose rights are being
violated those are the ones who care the
most about their own rights those are
historically the agents have changed
just like American blacks in the south
where the agents of change in the US
civil rights movement what the rest of
us can do is advocate and support them
and certainly here is a kind of action
plan we can we can yes protests when US
aid dollars go to autocrats that
directly repress their own people we can
protest even more when our own agencies
with their own projects violate the
rights of poor people we cannot let the
World Bank get away with a project that
was even on the front page of the New
York Times and yet they suffered no
consequences for that the moral universe
of development has to change to make
that no longer acceptable and so that
will enable us to be critics and
protesters about an unacceptable status
quo out of alliance of what used to be
colonialism and and violations of poor
people's rights is today a alliance of
u.s. foreign policy and violations of
poor people's rights we can step outside
of the aid world and be part
paid openly without censorship without
censoring ourselves in the global debate
on autocracy versus democracy we can
look ourselves for the Martin Luther
King's that are emerging all over the
world and support them and not support
the oppressors that are keeping them in
jail so to give one example there's a
very courageous Ethiopian blogger and
dissident name eskinder nega was put in
jail by Melissa now in 2012 and is in
jail for eight an 18-year sentence for
doing nothing but peacefully advocating
democracy in Ethiopia and we are paying
his jailers because our our US tax
dollars go to projects as a port the
Ethiopian government paying the salaries
of the jailers of eskinder nega we can
instead not give intellectual legitimacy
to the Ethiopian autocrats not give a
little intellectual legitimacy to allies
of convenience in the war on terror but
advocate for poor people's rights so we
must indeed join the moral debate on
freedom around the world that is
happening in places from Hong Kong to
Venezuela to Turkey to Hungary to
Ukraine to Ethiopia at uganda it's
happening all over the world it's very
complex the good guys and the bad guys
are not always crystal clear but what is
crystal clear is that it's not
acceptable that people are be held by
the oppressors without freedom without
rights we must convince many more to
care about rights for the poor we must
convince many more that all men and
women black and white deserve really to
be free at last free at last free at
last thank you very much
you